[Музика]
привіт мої дорогі студенти, мені приємно знову бути
тут з вами, це знову я
Олена, ви мене вже добре знаєте, і
у нас тут урок англійської мови, п'ять,
просто потрібно, щоб ми намалювали тут, який зворотний
від себе
їй вдалося  через Schneider - Righto Lana
чи є Рібізі Вітні буддійський лама
оптимальним Я не бачу, що Рой м'яко його накрутив
за останній раз, коли ми почали говорити
про предмети марнославства, вамос
офіційно Гувер це підходить, що
Кавані Маноло Каразо
святкування святкування свят
фестивалі паради карнавали ділитися
особистою перспективою Махабхарати
vltava cheer ki Carnevale festive Olli
і сьогодні ми будемо говорити про
конкретні свята, тому коли ви наливаєте воду
більше розбитих, створюючи дані в Україні
правильно, я хочу, щоб ви подивилися на
картинку, є кілька фотографій деяких
свят з лайна про вас сьогодні
cake or pinky my lungi perv next God,
тож перше завдання для тебе - це вгадати й
сказати мені, які ці свята холодні,
так, так loo  k на картинці і спробуйте
назвати свята, які ви бачите на
екрані або розділити прибуток diamo
padam my yak nom knows what, якщо вона
побачить зверху наприклад першу картинку
ви можете побачити красиву новорічну ялинку або
ялинку Abacha  Махараджа
буде займатися фотографією, або GE
зловить цю новорічну ніч, ніхто не
пропусти втомлено, що з того
, так що подивіться на другу картинку, на
якій ви можете побачити натовп людей, це,
ймовірно, центральна площа або
вулиця міста та  ви можете побачити багато
повітряних куль, і всі ці повітряні кулі
жовто-блакитні Shama bachi Mumbai to
mobile вибрав багато синього де aqui
Шастрі диван Mo's Levana центральне
працевлаштування mr.  mo ba Chi Medusa Baha
- Pavitra змушує вас виглядати короткочасним
свідком, так що, на вашу думку, це означає
так, що це означає, чи
незалежний день чи знаєте ви, що це за
день незалежності День незалежності
насадка, як вкладення Я думаю, що це
зображення  дуже зрозуміло, і я сподіваюся, що у вас
також є чудова традиція
відвідувати різні будинки і просто співати
пісні, щоб співати різдвяні пісні, щоб
ви точно могли сказати, яке це свято,
тобто Різдво. Я отримую місію, я
кажу, мій дядько каже, що Реза Міла так
надає вам  вартість Slee do
it's кожна серветка Tredici кажуть, що вона позбавлена
жету geeky оцінюйте без кольорового ключа та
, так що вони співають різдвяні пі
ні вони в красивих традиційних ук
аїнських костюмах добре, що з того, я
умаю, що це дуже легко тому, хто ма
фарбовані яйця голос Тауріма
Любочак Майкл Мумма знизу вгору
з тортиком російський чай що це таке, що ви
можете перевірити це, що я називаю ммм
бача Мата кі, якщо я зруйную кена
дійсність  так, ми називаємо це Великдень
англійською, а це
зображення двох прекрасних українок
Іванки, так, наші традиційні костюми,
так які вони можуть бути,
це Mashable сьогодні питання, які ми
можемо врятувати український,
він старий тоді, як білі
англійські Avanti, які  День Іванки,
як правило, навесні в травні, коли всі
носять гарний
український традиційний одяг і
просто виходять на вулицю погуляти, і я
особисто люблю цей день, це дивно, а
що
це може бути складно, я кажу, багато печінки,
ммм, ніколи не слід  зустрів ключ, який залишив Будда,
Лі Хюк Хюк зробив це додому трохи
нахабні знімки Боуї, уявіть
собі, гуляє стріла,
я зберігаю нагадування, ваше серце навіть знає,
який ключ ви не можете вважати буддійським
девізом. На
цій картинці зображено двох жінок, які
тримають у руках  їхні вінки
так яке свято може бути скажімо Івана
купола немає журавлів каскад він
цілує який диван Politico so mu
ho loopner так це називається  d диван
купол дуже гарний дуже старе
свято, історія якого
сягає давніх часів у білому
шерифі журнал Riviera omnes Мартін
попіл баштові крани можуть орендувати примо
Новий рік або якщо de novo Viroqua
зв'язати кожну нішу Новий рік  або Новий
рік День Незалежності потім як Леснеські
Різдво вклони зап'ясті навіть день купола або
навіть свято купола Україна і
Siobhan Kidane датська Іванка уклін
Пасха сер Буллок день ми Китай в
Bajada побудований перший день поцілунок
предикатив ібрагім абу Ді Маджіо  beretta,
тож давайте переглянемо, що таке святкування
, головне питання, що таке
святкування, коротший випадок з Co Ваня,
письменник, якийсь професіонал Кадіма рухається
Роберто Каваллі,
горілка Ваня святкування - це дія
святкування важливого дня Томас
Лукума Хікіс звільняв
підрівень Якудза дуже особистий
момент гордості чи щастя
Маші особисто потрібні ключі WrestleMania aboya
момент a-rod виписується сімейні
збори khaleesi  мені Родімус наречена
вирішити вечірку була друзями, які тут
cos truism фестиваль або велике зібрання,
перш за все на борту
Великої церемонії Лукас Прата є
який chavalla quick el castillo de
професійне свято пророцтво не
релігійне свято релігія має
національне свято  або святковий день
Abu Nazir Nana Giotto e OS tacos Slava
Yossef Rossi дайте mojit do дозвольте
відновлення, щоб проспекти не забудьте
їх спустити, будь ласка,
я знаю, що у вас є ваші англійські книги,
ваші книги англійською мовою, тому, будь ласка, не
забудьте  запишіть усі слова, які
ви не пам'ятаєте,
особливо коли у вас є переклад, тож
якщо вам ліньки шукати в
словнику, ви можете просто записати
слова, і у вас є переклад на
дошці, тому святкування Кампанії
святкуйте cubot національне свято
давайте ваші 9-ки не релігійне
свято релігійно автобус горілка
вино ваше особисте свято чи якась
справа не професійне святкування
пророцтво фестиваль фести  val святкові
набори помазати його святкування АТО
особливий випадок або метро ми будемо
Paducah Bo cassia державне свято
nacionales вертикально так вдаримо мене
черепом у фіолетову діву Мейснер Колін
Додд
так, так що це лише деякі дати
свят, коли у нас вихідний день
і  художньо ім'я здавалося корисним
прихованим однаково вічний Несс Отто
Сідней це урвати в твоєму кутку
Колліна Дейлі
якщо Нехемія Мохіні так так це
називається фестивалі чи свята в Україні
в січні штовхають джина CFC
Новий рік, який я знаю заново її
Окінавський вчинок і Різдво і, будь ласка,
запам'ятайте дату, яку я знаю, яку ви знаєте,
коли ми святкуємо Різдво, але ми
поговоримо про це пізніше
момент, як винний у
чистому ludus, що ми радимо йому piatto
через
це неможливо перейти через це, що
щодо березня у нас жіночий день, який є
8 березня мене зустрів ResNet
Сем не національний сьогодні нормально квітень у
квітні ми зазвичай святкуємо Великдень, але
іноді це відбувається в травні, як ви могли
помітити, там написано, що дата змінна,
Якумо Купер зустрінеться в той час, коли
людина дата змінна  лікарі
аміна крапка о так вірю в ім'я Яніс
я сумнівався, що незайманий восьминіг Тіна крапка
чесний Міннесота Мозес, який я повинен
стати надто стриманим зображенням, навіть якщо
травестія каже мініатюру, що ми
маємо в штаті Мен, у нас зазвичай День праці
та День Перемоги
О Джо оглядач Вахіні  Парша, який намалював
Другу війну Viata home travná ми маємо
День праці та День Перемоги, добре,
у червні є велике національне
свято, а каштани, твій кулак
охороняється, що це, хлопчик schmohawk
Чарлі, мабуть, cuomo Дейн входить
у День Конституції США та ще один
дійсно великий  національне свято
відзначається 24 серпня порівняно з
Днем незалежності Сербії, де гніздилися гондоли
Ден, а також у нас
вихідний у жовтні 14-го.  f
Жовтень ми святкуємо День засновників,
потім Жака Накія Чесні
День засновників, а також є
цікава річ у грудні,
починаючи з попереднього минулого року, коли
ми почали святкувати Різдво
25 грудня, ми все ще святкуємо наше
Різдво 7 числа  Січень, але у нас
є ще один додатковий вихідний, додатковий
вихідний 25 грудня, впевнений, кого вона
має жаліти з іншими на нас,
але категорія клієнтів cotta bleach Емма,
оскільки ідіотська eveness так, Yahoo досягла
чоловічої категорії автомобіля Purdue о, так
круто: кома мазума свідок  tthe incest
fiato
так що ми маємо особисті
святкування наші автобуси латавія
Ваня професійні свята пророцтво
це Рита національні свята матеріал зараз
міс Ріта релігійні свята дійсно
огидна Рита та інші свята, які
дюйм це життєво людські емоції фільм
гніздо змінити катер Гаваї ви
розділіть  padieu mama якщо у нас
день вчителя, який сьогодні день, яке
свято  це релігійне це
національне чи це особисте ні це
професійно, тому що день усіх
вчителів, яких люди в пророцтві
знають правильно, народжений абрикосовий день лікаря
на борту літака Lee Korea або день бухгалтера, день
Будди в Бохолі, терра, бу-бу-жокей,
великий спорідненість у Будди  професор, ми називаємо
ці свята професійними святами, а
щодо особистого шамана було понижено
в посаді головна книга: співпраця також сприяє вихованню домашніх дітей Кевона Ямана, оскільки він
жив мудро, наш день народження так,
це головне особисте святкування, яке ми
могли б святкувати месу тато невралгія або,
наприклад, ім'я  день, це також наша
особиста подія, і ми вирішуємо,
хочемо ми його святкувати чи ні
до особистих свят до
lamo Guillermo проукраїнська школа є
Mia вище нині армія
України укр.  День Збройних Сил або День Української
армії ви можете побачити Отто причина
пророцтво ні що про Великдень і
Різдво короткі стек Великдень і
Різдво Волок копати це бал
звичайно це
релігійні свята і Свята Трійця дата
ідентичність питання не сидить
усно він  наступний день захисників Бога,
що національне свято Пам ти дієта
національні свята, коли у нас
дні цунамі естетична хвороба рік ми
сховали мене міська щілина я думаю, ми могли б продати
назву курсу шана аніма шукран
але захисники вони ходять на
національні свята однаково  як
день Конституції податок мій вміст йде на
службу День Незалежності Дана велика
команда і ось все я думаю так
з'їсти вартість мсьє : автомобіль дюйми Фіат
академічний рух був свідком абрикосового
Нового року хлопчик
Першоквітневий перчик В'єтнам потім під час абрикосового
лікаря  інші свята про Новий рік,
а потім навахо Codetalkers Будда інші
свята над Шивон кадай уклін Івана
купола день так в основному  це
свята, які ми зазвичай святкуємо в
Україні, і це таблиця, як вона
має виглядати, так,
так вона розставляє всі свята за
різними категоріями ваш особистий
професійний національний релігійний та
інші, якщо Чавес Надяк хоче
встати, але засвоює kiyoung  google в
основному депонує це належним чином його
сприйняття сьогодні,
мусульманин де акі пророцтво
, рівень Фатаха Обами дійсно дуже огидний, але
ITA Chianina pasado skill Kiki Luger
burrata oh yeah boo brat Lucia була
відома ETA cos Naya обережно, тому це
також невелике завдання для вас, яке ви можете
виконати  у цій таблиці ви можете думати про
деякі інші свята, і ви можете заповнити
цю таблицю добре,
і я вирішив трохи поговорити про
одне з найважливіших релігійних
свят,
власну Родезію снайпера, гарний Wiggly
Shaheen. Я відкладаю релігію, це
не ваша дійсність, тому ми  матиме
невелике завдання, яке ми повинні будемо
заповнити, у нас буде словниковий запас із
кількома великодніми словами, і нам доведеться  виконайте
це завдання разом, коли вас
попросять спати на двоярусному двоярусному сні – це масовий обама,
який багато хто передає в Бухарест один
одному, що ви про це говорите,
ймовірність, тому ми дізнаємося
трохи більше про це свято про
нашу традицію, як його святкувати та
також вам доведеться виконати завдання
заповнити прогалини.
Посада
це доки Кім завершує в
резюме в закритому шапочці спитай жінку
є - блює паска що Україна
через млин О Боже поклони церкву Сара
Паско
так це паска сім'я Родіна
сини мир мені яйця да це великий
обід  хуліган Чесні або бісер, привіт
, зрозуміло, а музика зрозуміла.
О, циганка la bahia de movin abuja довготривала
Yvonne Buddha dosha Pro зупиняє планшет із
сидіннями, це надійний ключ з обручем Lavar, тож ви
можете почати це робити  зі мною, мабуть,
ви достатньо розумні, щоб зробити це дуже
швидко,
так, ймовірно, мені знадобиться більше часу
, щоб заповнити прогалини, тому ви робите
це разом зі мною, і я
допоможу вам трохи налаштуватися
на наступному слайді  ми перевіримо, що ми
зробили, тож давайте прочитаємо цей лист, надішліть
нам мудрість, я сподіваюся щоразу, любий
Девід, Великдень – це велике свято в
Україні, мабуть, немає жодних емоцій, які вдарять по
цьому добре, ведучий Великдень – це чудова
святкова подорож Лукас V Отто бу плач
ask wicomoco bottom approach вірити в
українське Великдень – це велике свято в
Україні у Великодню неділю
О, леді Лю роман в день люди зазвичай
ходять до Луїзи, я вважаю, що це може
навіть Hodges schuba Массімо Братислава
Прелюдія вони зазвичай ходять до церкви
прямо вони ходять до церкви дають  дякую
Богу, пісні про гріх слухати музику Я думаю, що
це дуже легко,
так, тому що ще можна співати пісні, які
зазвичай бачите, коли ви проводите
дуже добре час, коли ви розважаєтеся, ваші
гріхові пісні, ви слухаєте музику та  ти
проводиш час з сім'єю та друзями
в Україні ми робимо український мій robo-moe
шомер альбом Україна ти запитав, чи це
викликало прискорене обслуговування Wapakoneta повинні
відкрити regina ми змушуємо Великдень взяти мене ми
вибираємо IMO можливо ми будемо Cortney досить
темрява, коли ми поставимо  кімчі ні
паска холодна
yok mu hanazawa paska так це наша
спеціальна назва для цієї української
паски паска називається Pascal ми
фарбуємо що ми фарбуємо яйця дві родини
мають велику вечерю, це дуже гарна
традиція, коли люди запрошують своїх
друзів  їхні родичі члени їхньої
родини і вони організовують дуже великий
обід і вони проводять час разом
привітайся з вашою родиною ваша
Дара дякую нам він розповідав нам
про цю дуже гарну традицію
святкувати Великдень у своїй родині та в
Україні останні номери  йти на південь від
Kuta de votre обов'язки Баку Vania valina
vu cranium так, то які слова ми
повинні пам'ятати, якщо ми хочемо ще раз поговорити про
Великдень, Великдень, Схід  er cake
Church Pasco sones
велика вечеря яйця сім'я і традиції Я
хочу показати вам цю картинку і я
хочу представити вам мою справді хорошу подругу
, чудову жінку і фантастичну
вчительку, її звуть Елейн,
і вона буде тут з нами сьогодні, і
вона  розповість вам свою історію і вона
розповість вам про українські традиції
за кордоном yahoo chauhan prestarted tsuzuku
davao lu ви знаєте
Jadhav з Chi Telenet котрий я уявляю собі
чотириразовий м К.У.Марченко навіть наша
експедиція проукраїнська державна релігійна
угода onnum я GM ludus burelu
ukraine's  kitra de Navitus vouch є
основним донумом, тому ми зателефонуємо їй за
хвилину, і вона розповість вам все
про святкування, які вона проводила, коли
жила за кордоном, добре, так що це моя хороша
подруга, яка чудова жінка,
і це фантастичний вчитель  її
звуть Еллен комерційний автомобіль і вона
розповість про українські традиції за кордоном
вона розповість вам все про свою
сімейну традицію і як святкували
Великдень  ах, так ми почнемо з Великодня
спочатку привіт дорога Поньо леночко і я
попрошу вас розповісти нашим студентам
про Великдень і великодні традиції, що
ви мали
привіт, приємно вас бачити
мене звуть Ленка я народився в Англії
мої батьки народилися в  Україна Цікаво,
чи можете ви здогадатися, з якого міста вони,
це починається з цифрового соку я, братику
, я дивився вгору, коли вперше приїхав
в Україну, щоб насправді попрацювати в легенді,
аплодисменти, так що перш за все я почну, що
я належу, я належу  до української
громади ми ходили в українську
школу, у нас також є церква, і ми
стежили за різними традиціями та
святами протягом року, і одне з
них було там,
як ви знаєте, Великдень вони лижуть зараз я
можу розповісти вам більше про  випустив, коли
я жив у Німеччині, також в
українській громаді, і Великдень був дуже
особливим на Великдень, ми ходили до
церкви, і, як ви знаєте, я дуже люблю
кольори, тому у мене був дуже барвистий
пасхальний кошик, коли один з моїх
гі  rlfriends вишили мені яскраву
стрілку крейдою Schnee і ми ходили до
церкви після церкви, це було
благословення їхніх кошиків, після цього вони
виконували різні великодні пісні під назвою
hey yoki, всі зазвичай вдягали
в нього шиванський ключ українські вишиванки
і це було дуже  особливий, тому що це
наче перші ознаки весни з
великою кількістю зелені, квітів і
співів, а потім після цього я
справді запрошую людей до себе до
великоднього сніданку, який мені дуже
подобається з макаронами, крейдою з човна
та ще приготованим  що смачно смачно
смачно добре сер, я думаю, так, це
було фантастично, дуже дякую, що
поділилися з нами своїми сімейними традиціями,
це було фантастично
і ви можете
побачити зображення, воно чорно-біле,
і якість не дуже гарна, але ви
можете побачити всіх тих смайликів і
дітей, які одягалися для Христа  mas
we're
budget the same lunatic або Pina Colada Johanna yeah cristela так що не з
нанорозмірними quiches lividious але вони
забезпечують вірменське дієслово або sub levo або -
служба не звертаючи уваги на мою навіть оцінку
дивана це бал,
тому Різдво - ще одне велике релігійне
свято в Україні  і це
мої зимові канікули, ми з друзями
проводимо тут різдвяні таб-шоу кращих,
так що це діти, які
відвідують інші будинки, вони ходять навколо,
вони відвідують своїх сусідів і своїх
друзів, і вони надсилають спеціальні різдвяні
пісні, які я виконую  як рідні
ми Сінан Халід, наші сини колада це
українська різдвяна пісня, тому я думаю,
що все дуже зрозуміло
без перекладу отримати вологу,
можливо, змочіть це звичайно Squarebob
ukraine якась їжа сама, що
зволікання цінуємо Dead Set о
так, це діти  хто
ходить, хто ходить у гості до своїх
друзів і сусідів і яких
бачать у красивих українських
колядках, які ми і  звичайно подзвони Халеду Кіму
добре, зараз я просто хочу тебе, у мене є мій куб
із запитаннями, ти пам'ятаєш мій куб,
він говорить, як хто, де що, коли та
інші питання WH так,
що не є Volvo, тепер
періодичний рукав o речі Патанія він
тримає мене ти  WH Slava WH є Нечаєв CZs
лава, але вона лежить мають міста італійських
слов'ян до котрих Найт каже WH хід
на Tecna про wh-питання Світовий
порядок
Macross Teixeira amo практично mo,
мабуть, ні для ходу художника що б
це не про це див.  Патанія, так,
це лише кілька прикладів, наприклад, коли
люди святкують Різдво
насамперед на першій позиції, встановлена пара-поз
иція — це логотип головного героя, ко
и чому де, що хто чому чому та
, наприклад, а потім ми використовуємо наші до
оміжні дієслова та особу  і
деякі інші дієслова, щоб ви могли прочитати
багато прикладів Bridget RT a prequel
de peau de BTC hokhmah для багато іншого
вона putana ображати інерцію фігня
осад роману Чилі не вчиться
S  вбивство Гарри дуже багато що
день Ісуса головний герой Августин
скупий апотема колишня Месопотамія кімчі
молодий хлопець, який знає шляхетність, був
батальйоном Halawa no break1 коли
люди святкують Різдво в Україні
чому люди ставлять прикраси, куди
люди ходять на Великдень  що
готують люди на Різдво хто приносить подарунки
дітям на Різдво у
що люди одягаються на який день
іванки чому людям подобаються
святкування робо-мое ішьяма Зари мене кинуть у свій
куб з усіма цими питаннями і я
буду задавати тобі запитання  і ви повинні
мені відповісти, я перевірю booboo
Cristo з цим транспортним засобом, але він полягає в тому, що
щодо Patania така ж зміна з
італійської повільної духовки, добре, якщо я покладу її
на дно, а він поставив це добре, тому
перший Troy у мене був  один коли я був
дитиною холодно, мабуть, не соромно,
Омаху вигнали їх добре, чи люди в Україні
святкують Великдень, так і ти знаєш
відповідь, ти повинен відповісти на неї разом
зі мною o  r Японія kalim емоція
пафосно
Людовік Реєс Ріку її дійсність, коли
люди в Україні чи українці
святкують Великдень Великдень святкується
зазвичай у потоці в квітні або травні і
давайте ще раз.
Я маю те, що я можу запитати у вас щось на кшталт, чи
б ви зазвичай хотіли  отримати як
подарунок на ваш день народження показує нам, що
я зроблю, але вилучу на Віа Крісті,
але вони всі, до бога,
дивляться на вас, що так, так що ви відповідаєте на мої
запитання,
а також записуєте свої запитання,
і ви
практикуєте формування чи запитання WH
правильно, добре, ми рухаємося далі, і у
нас є невелика вікторина, і в мене є мої
маленькі помічники, тому я маю правильні відповіді.
B або C буде читати нашу вікторину разом,
і я покажу вам правильну
відповідь, це буде A або B або
С почнемо
так, що перше запитання – Різдво, а
дещо – державні свята в Україні.
ри Днем є
державні свята в Україні державні або
державні свята
№ два вул.  День Святого Валентина і ще
один не вихідні дні vltava
Valentina EJ Keith Chest yo ho Perico
може тут ми досягнемо ліміту намішями Барама
Тари День народження Шевченка День Конституції
або
Великдень звичайно правильна відповідь хоча
це свято дуже важливе і ми
повинні пам'ятати про  поспішати Шевченка і
багато людей святкували, що це не вихідний
так, наступний 24 серпня
показує перевагу мусульман там, де
сироп Touhou зараз день народження Тари
Шевченка День Перемоги день народження
нашої країни показує перевагу вакууму
це було для мене  солодкий ми мо день народження
нашої країни
Cedeno ревність T зобов'язаний пан.  Хамід
сказав, що поживний і запевняючий
день незалежності Кореї або народження нашої
країни, і правильна
відповідь - C, і остання відповідь на
День незалежності, яку люди можуть показати,
завантажена з анодною роздільною здатністю, - це
прикрасити новорічну ялинку, дивитися
феєрверк, фарбувати яйця, зв'язувати  троянда мальва
уникати закоханості в ключ, коли день леза
на салют ми працюємо Beaupre
закохатися над досягненням надара цілі з
вашим віршем на День незалежності, тоді
запрошена ревність має працювати над сер,
ми, Китай, проблема має це з Буддою, щоб
люди дивилися феєрверк на
День Незалежності
ось на сьогодні дякую
за увагу ваші чудові
студенти і мені дуже приємно
бути з вами я бажаю вам удачі я бажаю
вам гарного дня до скорого побачення
[Музика]
ви